i think we're all an underdog  i think i think the top ceo on the  planet earth still has that doubt yeah i  don't give a [ __ ] where you're from kobe  bryant michael jordan the best on the  planet we're all underdogs  whether you're underdog because you put  yourself there to be hungry  or yes a real life underdog we're all an  underdog  and so this this is about  the mind and people  discovering the mind their own mind and  one thing i know is we all have an  equation  we all have an equation like you know  i'll talk about three point you know  3.14 is pi  there's different equations to figure  out different kind of you know  mathematical problems we as human beings  are mathematical problems  i cannot give you a book  for every body in this world